IP rights well what happened was me a
lot English
so long English does artists like only
one they honestly have been cause that
it's honour for them to draw their stuff
and of course they don't come after I
told I understand they did some sense he
was actually the episode of Smith this
is [ __ ] amazing
oh thank you it's look so crazy so what
to do nothing that's it this is it I got
it I got it no first time anyone's
seeing it yeah [ __ ] dropping
exclusives around here
dude it's fresh how much is it gonna be
650 love him we're gonna do oh we're
doing Tyler I want one well totally it's
a buy one I was doing the painting you
did a painting we're doing prints or did
a situation where there's actually gonna
make purple hats to match it just trying
to and we doing the wreck how many of
those we're doing um and we're doing
that's by mall and then pricing the next
day I know what kill so ended up doing
two records I did one record with smoke
there's a Dave East currency of style
speak all inhale exhale love it and then
another record down with Westside gun in
Conway and how come is did to be because
our toys never had Oh acting like you're
preaching so excited it's like weed out
of hip-hop
I don't know we don't have good albums
there might be some truth than that I
want to come through I've got a I know I
know I was look at you and then like I
never have no time but like how do we do
it
you know what I should go to eat you
know what I've been on like a real kick
yeah I've been wanting to do a Yankees
game with playa now just like I never do
anything for real life anymore
so why don't I go to a Yankee game while
my fantasy yeah while my fantasy yeah
exactly while my fantasy team is still
good and I'll actually have a good time
at the Yankee game why don't we pick a
Yankee game in what are we in May
late-may early-june yeah yeah exactly
I'll come up there like 5:00 5:30
well we'll chop for an hour an eloquent
the game now be life
okay I want to do that I've been wanting
to it's a love it yeah I know I see it I
know it I know I love I just want to
come through so once it's going when's
this going out with 2000 online and only
you know then I'm gonna do an event 100
concepts to just how many how many are
gonna be sold on 4/20 on the website oh
so you mean how many of those again oh
that's right 400 yeah and then a hundred
thousand it's probably gonna sell out
real quick right those go we sold under
the black Charlie Brown yeah we did 600
three minutes yeah how do we make sure
we buy one don't mean I'll just yours
the street I get him in I really believe
man actually want to so we've got one
that's tree and I think that's cool and
that's fair but I want to buy a couple
more and if we get him we get him if we
don't we go I know but I appreciate it
but it's actually so we does the thing
called the blind bag so it's a couple of
different colors of them so these are
the production that's getting done at
Hong Kong then we're doing those are
like the gold pop ones with this gold
smiley face and then a silver so I'll
make sure you get all set that never do
lucam like surprised [ __ ] what do
they call it you guys are all too young
for this woot.com was a game changer for
me
you remember woo wo t back in day you're
a kid right remember is a crazy [ __ ]
like they would have discounted [ __ ] was
that was like the early deal the day
[ __ ] that was the early Groupon and was
I bought weed and they just started
doing gate was telling me yesterday like
fresh off the try super-low day how
after you drop it Tori man well now my
goal this year that this one slated I'm
looking at for this year it was one
right now this one I got a little bit
almost are and how do you and how do you
brand you and your world in it if at all
well so that's this is prototype I'm
gonna be
pounds gonna be on there it won't be on
the compounds on the toys what it was is
I I hope that would like looked at the
toys getting like mixtapes right so a
new hardest want to give the game I go
if I do a mix tape I'm hot by myself but
I really got to get cosines or other
people for people like you
you're talking you're talking about life
pretty much life you tell my life so I
did that we are and I said because all
you collected collect what loves it I
was like okay I think it was running
this was my first established artists
and what it was is always so brought up
of course in my effort
I forgot you watch the cartoons or never
know the spins okay our culture what I
found out Bert they came some heavy so
way later I get it I get it before Cosby
was but so then the second part I was
like wow a lot of fan hours no hip-hop
connected to it so I was like wow so the
first thing we did he had a Charlie
brother was just regular with a grant
and I was like let me let's make a black
Charlie Brown
so then Charlie Brown was ill when he
did the pictures man that was the one
time Charlie Brown had a hat on was my
swag I remember Alan and I was like yo
Charlie Brown been involved with that so
and then when you broke Charlie Brown
down he was like he was a rapper yeah
the whole squad and he was like no
matter what happened he was the coolest
guy everybody worth hanging with Lucy
was a hater all the time but he never
kicked out the group she kept me with
football I was like you know that's
round let's do a blank Charlie Brown's
that's a mean we put it girls money and
then everybody loves so then you know
now let's play okay spongebob anybody to
really watch plays that was hot a
hundred percent I was like wow there
needs to be let's put that together
let's put a spongebob and I wanted to go
and now everybody live like yo are even
but really we had that you know hazel
and I girl everything that I want to do
is one thing to look at it feel
marketing is if you connect a culture to
anything the antidote and so yeah so
first one was pretzels now we're I can't
wait I can't I can't tell you I just
can't
because it's putting somebody on blast
but we you and I are gonna have a real
conversation in the fall based on this
entire thesis I'm gonna do some business
together and you're gonna be real happy
with me I got a real idea I'm ready I
figure like you know did it was before
when I created the n1 mixtape that I was
like I changed the world on a change
culture 100,000% 100,000% like that's
just the truth and by the way it's a
replicatable thing totally and once you
you cuz you just see the pattern and
that's what I do
yeah I'm doing it again in this lane so
and that's fun for you because it's like
a it's real to you but you know what so
I got a question that good buddy what's
your first love
my first love was I can I can figure
this out actually I want to give you the
real answer it's a real good one my
first love was probably
Batman and Robin the way you're talking
about my mom was my first Slevin the
first thing I remember loving when we
came to cuz I I wasn't born in America
so I was literally do you know what was
going through my mind right now the
great space coaster Batman and Robin the
old Adam West Show The Flintstones price
is right
those were the core things of how I've
learned how to speak English those were
things I liked that I loved you know and
then the real one like those might be
like the you know this is why I want to
buy the New York Jets probably my first
love is the New York Jets
because that was the thing a year later
that made all the other kids except me
and I was like now I'm an American
calling uncle I'm an American
okay so I think everybody's wrong but
I'm not gonna get the answer I love that
so what's the answer love is a toy your
parents had you and you guys put you in
the crib they gave you a teddy bear they
gave you something
you don't remember sent but just a repro
hundred percent knows that I believe
that to be true and the best part is you
know for everybody listening a lot of
people came from nothing like I know for
facts
I had nothing but the toy was some Pete
like fabric right it was a thing it was
something it was a thing my blankie was
a thing was the thing so with the toy
when you loved it it might have been a
pacifier with a barrel and yeah it might
have been a bottle with ears yeah it was
some type of toy and ever but everybody
answers something that was five or six
or seven years old but the answer was
one day old it's one day it's no it's
literally like three months seven my man
it's why you love your parents the most
even when they do the most [ __ ] up
[ __ ] because because that was actually
the first person yeah and then right and
never made you think about it cuz you're
going to the first thing you love that
was material outside of to humans that
popped you the [ __ ] out and they use
this to shut you up
cuz the umbilical cord is probably
number one yeah yeah why do you take my
[ __ ] man you might have to make an
umbilical cord with toy boy I better get
some [ __ ] cosign
yeah cuz that's probably it yeah that's
probably a you lose a hundred percent
okay yeah I listen your preach I mean
you know what do you know why I'm so
happy right now because in 15 days I'm
going garage saleing for the first time
in the year and that's like my opening
day and that is all I'm looking for is
[ __ ] like this like finding like a
pop-culture
1987 thing for 40 cents in somebody's
box that's my jam jam jam my life I get
a bigger high in two Saturdays three
Saturdays because three Saturdays I will
get a bigger high by buying I bought a
[ __ ] Thundercat in package for a
dollar last year that high when I would
walk and it was late because now I'm
taking like now it's more like I'm doing
it for me and my kids it's like our
bonding so like I'm not waking them up
at 4:30 because to get the real [ __ ] you
gotta get up early good so yeah so this
is like I'm leaving that like you know 9
o'clock it's loser [ __ ] cuz the kids but
I'm still getting Jersey by 10 so I
don't think I'm getting anything it's
more about buying them [ __ ] and get him
on the game but [ __ ] at noon noon I
don't know what the [ __ ] people were
doing on a Saturday I pulled his house I
look thundercat in package ago how much
you want for that she goes $1.00 I go
okay that was mom bruh I [ __ ] grabbed
it and I was like yo the high that I got
compared to me closing an 11 million
dollar deal right now said mom bro not
even close your folder and I'm talking
and I'm talking like I'm the Delta like
I can't replicate the high of finding
some [ __ ] in a garage sale that I buy
for a dollar that's worth 20 and oh well
I I just I can not replicate that high
the thrill of the hunt is that you love
that [ __ ] that's my everyday I can't a
man with fashion so yeah I get it
give me they'll give me something give
me the last fine you found that was
crazy like real crazy
I mean I found a pair of Gucci loafers
for like 15 bucks a couple days ago but
like I find it's not fun stuff every day
like I wear like Goodwill yeah goodwill
just all kinds but I shop like suburbs
that's that's core to many supply and
demand of course no kid rub up for real
for real that was the whole kid robot
babe like 2005 mm yeah you might hear
some great back to Bronx
remember thrift land is he still there
cuz he used to be right next to Yankee
Stadium yeah I walked through the thrift
land in 1996 I'd never gone before we
went to a Yankee game I was like oh [ __ ]
thrift Lin let me walk in there cuz I
was against thrift stores because it was
too expensive I was pure garage sale if
it's over dollar [ __ ] you got it yeah
like real like mainly cuz I was doing
pre-internet good when I was buying like
a box of Hemans for 4 bucks
you know and ljn's wrestlers I used to
kill on that and then video games is
where I made my real just the fun that
was the biggest arbitrage hundred
percent like rent them out yeah yeah
here's my rad racer give it back give it
back in a week and then two days later
you have to fight you know I remember
you know nonetheless I wasn't a thrift
land I never went to the Yankee game I
got there this man that this is early
this is before people buying video games
like that this man had 2,000 Atari games
and a thousand Nintendo games so I start
going through them like looking for the
right [ __ ] and right away I found crazy
climber for Atari 2600 and manual 180
bucks right and it's a dollar piece
right right off the bat a mail away game
cuz I [ __ ] I used to memorize [ __ ] no
phone no phone
still used to [ __ ] literally stay up
at night for like four hours memorizing
[ __ ] figuring out which rock-and-roll
t-shirts worth money and which ones
weren't memorized everything so finally
I was like is the owner here cuz I'm
going through it I'm fine and [ __ ] I was
like nobody's been through here and it's
like right next to Yankees same so I was
there trying to find like one little
like nut you know and I'm like why you
know he comes over he was there thank
God I go how much have I bought every
video game you had it what do you know
what he know classic Braham what do you
mean I'm like okay let me break it down
if I buy all the video games what price
can I get a volume discount he goes he's
like I'll give you yeah you could take
half off he goes take him all all like
don't you know like and this was back in
the day when I didn't have an ATM card
and I used to carry money in splaying
you know we're older right they don't
know and now I got four dollars on me at
all times I used to when I was like 16 I
like $2,000 at me at all times never
knew when you're gonna find something
[ __ ] bought it all out it was the
greatest day of like my atari 2600 and
Nintendo NES and it was I mean it's 17
Contras you know 17 Contras which are
like 20 or 30 now and I mean that whole
market what has gone up by like a
hundred percent or like when people like
yo Gary Vee twitch you're on Italy and
like [ __ ] I was on this ship
before you born like you know what I
mean I was like I [ __ ] I knew Zelda
was before your mom and dad even kissed
yeah anyway yeah so that's awesome
working on my documentary now then one
mixtape
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]